who normally
searches for find kliemann on youtube gets
interesting videos from fynn in this case
not here there is only audio
but there is information and
insights to be found that he
would not tell anywhere else here he
hears different works finding children is
really
welcome  to the mr podcast an
old friend of the house is back
we are talking after two years i
think again about the empire the climate
19 hello hello
well I'm in a good mood now I
was in a great mood so no jingle also
mega mega I like the whole thing
very thin also agrees exactly the
originator of the things now speaks on
his own topic
during last year you
spoke and I talked to jan that
was such a special cup miram association
head is that i think jan
delay was shocked that i thought
he was  I think 30 million people must be
really deeply moving for a
long time to
come b  still purple but also bread
so already in geisenheim and out there
so here is a reference to a completely new record
but we want to talk about
what happened to you when we
were there at the rimc abroad two years
ago there was such a thing  topic
I would have thought about your agency you were there because you were
making an album
and the climate is then to be set
in motion, so to speak, which is
also very strong, above all,
somehow youtuber influenza and
now I have just auditioned a bit
it reads like this you have
a real real estate group then
you somehow have sonne crypto you have
everything clear well then you have in the
textile business so we first have to work our
way slowly through what i
start with real estate yes whatever you want i don’t
care i think these
we're abstract about terms that always
sounds like a banknote somehow but
it's always so close that everything is
accidental there too  h really it
started with brian was on vacation
with a houseboat like that and then he would have i
have i look on ebay classified ads
for crazy things everything is possible
and he built trackers himself they
have no idea what and of course they
also take houses and everything  it can
fall into my hands and there was a
recreation center run by the stasi there used to be
a probe the day of recreation the
sound was right there there was half of
it that was the plus that no
one wanted to buy i pricked up my
ears because there were so many
people see in it they
don't have these visions they do the cologne woman
so if something has been empty for a long time
i say that's a sign that it
's probably cool i think it
's often a
houseboat but in the end it's often like that
an introduction to the fact that people
just don't have enough imagination and that was
the way it was and then when I
called him he happened to be
near e  s in brandenburg where he finished reading exactly that
hour from berlin up to the north sea in
between
you still have something to say exactly there
is this feldberg lake district or
something like
that it’s easy there are many ponds it’s
wet everywhere
there’s that thing then i’ve got it  sent there
and called
the realtor one could burn two real estate
professionals and said
then they shuffled there completely
screwed up and
we went through it with Facetime and I
mean that making the holiday is so hot
and
then I got it directly over the phone
bought
it wasn't that expensive anymore say
several million
that's it used to cost half a million
or something and then it was bought
too much 250 and then what
did you do what did you do because I wanted to,
I didn't really know that then either
At first I thought these are
bungalows, they will probably have to be
made fit again somehow, and so the
main building was also a gastro
nomie and more apartments and stuff like that i
didn't know anything actually just
thought it was cool thought he could go on vacation with all
your friends or something and
then i looked at the problem
wet was that's a big problem they
have no idea there are  somehow
300 painters moved into the top floor
during the handover what you have
totally
sucks we had water damage in two of the
main houses so we
now have a fact is that looks
everything i bought that has to be a
higher house yes yes exactly actually
exactly  actually let the same story be
dazzled by vacation spots and that's
exactly when i noticed
i don't think i can do it on my own and
then i thought about
the whole construct
and founded clean holding structures
built craft business five
people hired craftsmen yes yes because
I know that  so this whole story is
always difficult to grasp it starts
with the schro  tt project by mistake and
then i think it can actually
be mapped holistically and
now i have the plan he has four properties
later i founded a craft
business around this there is such a
problem apparently everyone hates
each other and everyone already knows
sometimes something did it always like that the
electrician blames the user
beforehand and what there is to say about everything
built so shitty here so don't
continue and I thought about it
I could do something like the
craftsmen avengers who are just too
but in the team  friends buddies
i give your car a lot of tools
time to realize itself then she
found it on the construction site and build
something awesome like that and then i have a
carpenter electrician now gas water and site
manager is but as probably well
full full has knows somehow
are cool guys unbound living in the
bus ver.di has recruited
or instagram and ability i have that yes  said i
want to found craftsmen avengers
then i received 1400 applications
within 24 hours and today
i was only able to bring out the beads
really jackpot but i
always got to
know how good the craft is
, so to speak, i called them and called them for a short phone call  and
those who thought it was cool i just
hired them over the phone and
then we started and now they’re
building in brandenburg because the house has
had several booths like i said
it just escalated totally then i had
the next thing was then i got  the
smallest house in germany was bought
and how many square meters of living space just saw in
the bild newspaper there it was that's
why everywhere i
saw it i have an assistant on
animals not that big and then
we joked about it it's perfect
the tip of the house would be so my colleague
would like to sell
that's cool or what's called but  they
liked it right away bought it always so
that then it was completely completely insane
too well that always sounds
as if I was somehow throwing money
around now that's I
didn't that's everything completely
financed and so no that's it  just
plans of the sink so bright how many idiots
are there out there renting out holiday apartments
i'll probably be able to
do that too and what's a
holiday apartment they're all ugly they
're shitty tiles table no love
somehow a sofa like that you
can wipe off so well and  so that in cases
apartment and i thought i can
actually also buy third fifth tenth
row not rented de because i
i can do that yes i make it
tasty i turn to lift to every
place there is an exclusive video like i
with my friends or something like that  half an
hour for half an hour there is a
teaser on youtube and then there is an
exclusive film that is only available on hardware
recorders  location is like that then you can
do a documentary per location do you know where
i button everything out for the people that
's the nice thing
that i do that i did all
this stuff well thought out last week brought in people
now i'm in frankfurt or still
bought a water tower like that in full
gelsing everything included so that’s
also a pianistic one so that’s
right I thought about it I still need it
somehow so it was in the east it was in the north
it was always a coincidence that
as I said it was the smallest house per the
tower was  ebay classifieds
again somehow seen it in the evening at ten o'clock in the evening there it's
advertised then he's not
shitty says heal crossed out
already a bit stricter yes
that's exactly unless you want it I
called that evening and he was
like that right away you have to do that  the only
thing I can give it is
that I have to say ok I'll take that now
I got along well with the
case with which I used the phone h  ört
as I said because we've talked for half an hour so far
and he likes he has
appointments for the whole next week and as
I said come on I'll just say he
deleted it everywhere in the evening
I clarified the next day with a notary and things like that and
then we'll have it all done  made
and then i flew down a week later
that was really funny
i called a buddy who
is half a pilot and would be and then
you have to get hours full i flew
to frankfurt or with his little
sister and to the
rothenburg and then  we once looked
at cook, which happened to be super
awesome and now we're doing everything piece by
piece like that and then you know
that what I mean holistically so I
have there then the next step was
that I say I
also have to equip there  something has to go in
, déco furniture and such, and i wrote to
all the people i
drive cool, canceled cool jobs, similar to build
something like that  n thing apparently this is
going to be an rbi whatever but i can do
it myself and that will be especially so
all the booths have it is somehow special
and i'm thinking about something
and so he doesn't have to be there
somehow good condition  why did they all offer me
ten percent and
I thought that what
I want to do here is not easy enough and then I
asked quite often they
always stuck to their ten percent
and I said I know for
myself then I got it  selected where
they order their stuff just had me listed
as a hospitality and
retailer and leg that's the name of the silver
let yourself go that's what it stands for that
will show you also act in the interior
why not i have a
distribution itself we have a warehouse in
cologne  and then they usually send the
clothes and I
sent them there and said you can
pack it here, then they tested it once,
we tested it e.g  since
stopped i'm doing now that i have to
yes i know i have to yes it works yes
i had to order the lamp for
the stalls more and then
i order from the retailer and i need two
where you buy 20 i have 18 more than
that means you  In the end, it's your goal
to have a portfolio of properties that
are all a bit unusual,
so the house Wasserturm is rather
small  in the end yes because it's not like that the
robinson club just say climate
what's cool yes there are a
few nice things everywhere and such and and as
i said yes the place is just awesome the
water tower for example is complete in the
morning that's four floors  it will
probably be two apartments because
they are not very precise either and above
it is an eight by eight so it is
eight meters in diameter eight meters deep
water tank that is on floors five and
six s  oh you can do something
three times we were in the pool then
i freeze the whole floor then
you have a kind of penthouse upstairs and
then you can go on the roof and then I have
soundings with the whirlpool manufacturer
who also comes to me more  the
paid crane and in the whirlpool that since
the deal because it's like that then I'll call everyone he
says I somehow accidentally
bought last night would be such
nonsense and then again it says there's
no electricity no water
I have big problems right away somehow in the evening
me  knows right away that he
bought it before i knew all that and
then i found out in the evening there was
no water and no electricity we
thought about it he was there then so brk ws
and so you call buderus
you tell them buck for something like that  wild
project i need the electricity with
me and that's how it works i
clarified everything within two hours
then i organized it and
i heard it  getting pretty crazy
about everything but you’ve known each other for a
long time now and you know that in the end it will work
out when I did,
fortunately I always had the ok quote
because it’s all a
bit stupid
if I didn’t know it  or
when i hear from her for the first time
if that doesn't belong now for the
first time today thinks okay who is that
guy the guy is definitely totally
over the top but the truth is yes i
mean the last project somehow houseboat
bought exactly the same logic and  it
now i think in the end not only a
whole house has become good but also
the film about it the documentary about it is
now one of the most successful focus with
a flex yes so that was only good in the
end if you take the thing with you
i do it now of course  The
advantage is that I also have a
production company, which means I can
always say hey, come on, get in
the car for a moment, let's meet
at the tower and  we'll take that with us, let's
see what comes out of it and then
you always have to do something like
that, yes exactly, yes,
it's always about the value chain
if you like, but only in the form of
I'm not in the mood for
anything with idiots  i
'd rather do it myself with my little
family and we can
do everything from as i said to
production now to the
craft itself i used to have an
antiques shop with little ones that means
we buy that's the way it's always
been  one two three years we want to
sell our old tunnels empty attics
like antiques and you'll be with
us but you seem to blame e-rolli
laugh me for that also endure for a while